mais d'abord direction les mureaux dans
les yvelines dans les pas d isabelle
borne avec cécile six ans pour ses
premiers pas sur le terrain elisabeth
bornes fraîchement nommé a choisi les
mureaux ville populaire et terre de
gauche où elle a échangé avec des
associations militantes sur l'égalité
des chances et l'émancipation des femmes
tu te sens comme chez moi c'est quand sa
famille et c'est tellement confiance en
toi tellement évident qu'apple
prime est copieux
après l'ouverture interrogé sur son
propos par la première mini qui trois
jours plus tôt avait conclu son discours
de passation 100% les jeunes filles à
aller au bout de leurs rêves a continué
sur sa lancée le point de départ c'est
un rêve et avoir confiance en soi ça
c'est les autres aussi qui peut vous
aider à construire cette confiance en
tout cas je pense que faut surtout pas
écouter tous ceux qui vous disent ce
métier là où cette voie n'est pas fait
pour toi il faut aller au bout de ses
rêves enfin tout le monde attendait un
mot sur la date et la composition de son
gouvernement mme elisabeth board n'a pas
cédé et a appelé à la patience eh bien
vous verrez vous voyez que c'est des
choix lourds qu'on a à faire il faut une
équipe pour mettre en oeuvre le projet
du président barack dick aussi aller aux
législatives soutenir la majorité
présidentielle parce qu'on a besoin
d'avoir une majorité à l'assemblée donc
on constitue l'équipe évidemment on
n'est pas en train de traîner je peux
vous assurer qu'on y travaille mais on
prendra le temps de trop pour avoir la
bonne série de coups interrogé quelques
minutes plus tard emmanuel macron a
également déclaré qu'il y travaillait
car jean futur gouvernement est une
chose sérieuse qui requiert du temps
voilà la composition la formation de ce
nouveau gouvernement mais aussi ce
premier déplacement d'elisabeth
born symbolique on en parle on en débat
tout de suite avec sa verrière ogec
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes journaliste
et éditorialiste politique sur france
info vous publiez résurrection ici de la
première année de la dernière année du
premier quinquennat macron publié aux
éditions aux stocks et puis bienvenue
chez vous avez fait combien de saisons
sur public sénat 11 chabat voilà vous
avez beaucoup plus de finalement
d'habitude et de connaissances que que
moi qui boucle ma première saison c'est
un plaisir de vous accueillir ici
frédéric potier bonsoir et bienvenue
bienvenue à vous aussi expert associé à
la fondation jean jaurès hauteur des
thrillers politiques la menace 732 7 aux
éditions de l'aube j'accueille également
stéphane sec ou bonsoir bien soin vous
êtes le directeur du département opinion
d'ipsos est ici accrue pas éditorialiste
politique à mes côtés bonsoir laetitia
heureux de vous accueillir également
alors on commence par ce premier
déplacement saveria héros jacques elle
choisit de parler égalité des chances et
de s'adresser aux femmes est ce que
c'est un engagement féministe de sa part
finalement c'est peut-être en tout cas
c'est peut-être on attendait un peu le
cap politique ça fait trois semaines
déjà qu'on attendait un ou une cata pour
matignon on attend aussi le cadre
politique de ce nouveau quinquennat
c'est vrai qu'on ne vient pas vraiment
on nous promet emmanuel macron lors de
son discours d'investiture avait promis
la nouveauté mais pour l'instant on
attend n'a toujours pas de gouvernement
et vous avez tout à fait raison de
remarquer que ce qu'on a eu c'est le
discours avant-hier deux d'eads isabelle
borne qui a effectivement fait appel à
ce rêve de petite fille en disant voilà
laissez vous tenter par tout va je crois
que je connais je me souviens plus des
mots exacts mais c'était quelque chose
de cet ordre là et l'appareil on voit
que ce premier déplacement c'est la
chaussure est qu'elle est lancée c'est
d'ailleurs le fait qu'elle est une femme
le fait que les petites filles de par là
ni monnayé sa nomination à matignon ne
doivent pas s'interdire quoi que ce soit
donc vous avez raison c'est peut-être en
tout cas une des indications du cap
politique de ce nouveau quinquennat qui
débute ferry potier comment vous
l'analysez ce premier déplacement à
d'abord c'est la consécration des
diabètes bourdin qui après avoir été
préfète de région patronne la ratp
ministre devient chef du gouvernement et
je crois que c'était un bon signal que
d'envoyer
d'envoyer le chef du gouvernement
dialoguer avec les jeunes du jeune femme
pas très loin de paris par devront quand
même puisqu'on est dans les yvelines
mais on sent bien quand même que tout le
monde est un peu en attente de la suite
et donc on sent que cette séquence est
un peu une séquence de temporisation
quand même terre de gauche on disait
dans le reportage s'est pas totalement
neutre quand même terre de gauche les
yvelines ne sont pas complètement donc
c'est un quartier populaire certes été
ça qu'il fallait retenir de la séquence
stéphane je ne sais comment vous le
voulez y est ce que c'est forcément sur
ce terrain qu'on l'attendait danser dans
ses premiers jours il y avait là
d'autres grands dossiers qui et qui
d'ailleurs ont été cités par emmanuel
macron dans son message d'entre eux en
quelque sorte d'accueil ou de bienvenue
sur sur twitter c'était une façon pour
elles aussi de surprendre un cerf ce
thème a été présent on a quand même
présidentielle on a bien vu de notamment
valérie pécresse avait cherché à
présenter ce sujet elle ne parle pas
pouvoir d'achat c'était tellement
attendu que quelque part c'est une façon
aussi prendre les gens n'ont pas à
contre-pied mais de montrer son
originalité on parlait tout à l'heure du
territoire des mureaux on le trouve que
ce déplacement et comme très éclairant
sur la stratégie la majorité
présidentielle et d'emmanuel macron
juste quelques chiffres et jean luc
mélenchon a obtenu 60 % des voix au
premier tour aux mureaux et emmanuel
macron uniquement 17% pourtant au second
tour et maniaque emmanuel macron obtenu
75 % et seulement 25% pour marine le pen
donc on voit bien et cette
circonscription est aujourd'hui détenue
par la majorité par le modem on voit
très clairement que la priorité va être
donnée dans cette campagne à toutes ces
circonscriptions qui sur le papier sont
en difficulté pourraient être perdues
par la majorité présidentielle l'idée
c'est au delà de l'image de quelqu'un
qui vient de la gauche l'idée c'est
vraiment de se dire il ya plus rien à
gratter ou très peu à droite la priorité
maintenant c'est de faire peur peut-être
en parlant aux français d'une éventuelle
victoire de la france insoumise où denis
pesce et donc de mettre l'accent et
c'est en cela qu'ils aient
born est un allié est un outil essentiel
pour le président de la république pour
aller essayer de récupérer ce qui peut
être récupéré dans ces circonscriptions
qui a priori sont presque perdu pour la
république en marche et pour ensemble
mais moi je me pose toujours la question
de la naïveté présupposés par la
majorité présidentielle des français du
public des gens qu'ils avaient demande
d'avoir pourquoi parce que cette
séquence elle est caricatural en termes
de communication politique c'est
vraiment écoute elisabeth tu vas y aller
tu vas fendre l'armure temps où on peut
déjà imaginer ce qui s'est dit en amont
voyez la préparation et puis tu vas à
jouer la carte de l'empathie et du coeur
du proche de du peuple des
préoccupations de gauche ça c'est
tellement gros que
parfois je trouve que le personnel
politique prend un peu les français pour
des idiots tout petit sa décision moi je
le connais ce symbole là sur la table ne
semble pas thomas que là est encore
complètement les mains libres dans le
choix de son premier déplacement
franchement je vous dis je pense que
manuel macro ayant choisi son directeur
de cabinet avant même qu'elle ne soit
nommé je pense qu'elle en fait référence
à emmanuel macron et que ses choix alors
on fait en ciment pas tout à fait
d'accord avec vous mais quand même pas
dupe non plus et je rejoins ce que vous
disiez de du calcul politique c'est à
dire que mémé même sûr mais même sur le
thème de l'émancipation des fins je vous
donner la parole saveria mais bon ça
n'échappe à personne autour de cette
table que la campagne de jean luc
mélenchon et de la nouvelle union
politique écologique et sociale elle est
empêtrée depuis plusieurs jours dans la
polémique autour des burkinis le
fondateur de l ehf il a dû répondre ce
matin une conférence de presse pour
présenter son programme évidemment c'est
venir sur le tapis il balaie les
accusations de communautarisme on écoute
il ya mieux à faire un que de discuter
les 6000 règlement intérieur des
piscines de ce pays en tout cas moi je
ne suis pas candidat à être premier
ministre des piscines
c'est pas c'est moi d'abord il ya la
question de comment je balaye cesse
cette polémique de la part de jean luc
mélenchon et puis je reviens à la
stratégie d'elisabeth borne est
peut-être derrière elle des manuels mais
je suis pas sûr que la stratégie d'aller
aux mureaux pour la majorité soit
effectivement de se noyer dans cette
polémique je pense que la majorité en
tous cas emmanuel macron est plutôt
content que effectivement la gauche se
noie assure voilà quand on va faire la
promotion des anticipations des femmes
on peut soumissionner s'est plongé dans
la même polémique en revanche je pense
qui est très symbolique effectivement
vous avez raison laetitia les ficelles
de la communication sont un peu grosses
était axé le dépassement aujourd'hui
c'est l'exact inverse de ce qu'elle est
on l'a dit dur on l'a dit sévère on l'a
lu bon voilà est donc là on essaye de
nos craintes et grad on essaie de la
montre et alain verte en revanche c'est
aussi je pense politiquement une façon
d'installer comme chef de la majorité je
vous rappelle que nous sommes bien
évidemment campagne législative que
jusqu'à présent il n'y avait pas de chef
de la majorité dans deux sets quand même
que la semaine dernière encore c'est
emmanuel macron qui est venu s'exprimer
devant tous les candidats investis par
la majorité présidentielle et que ce
type de déplacement c'est aussi de voir
est ce que d'isabelle board en tant que
premier ministre peut faire gagner des
points dans certaines circonscriptions
et l'installer l'instaurer en tant que
chef de la majorité donc un gain
politique je pense à jouer là dessus
demain le coup elle fait son premier
déplacement dans le calvados où la haie
directement candidat tout d'ailleurs
elle joue alors bon là vous allez
pouvoir nous dire si la circonscription
est difficile a plutôt favorables alors
il n'y a pas de hasard mais quand même
il ya un petit risque des petits mais il
ya un petit risque peut-être finir sur
les yvelines son propre chef de quai
mais par ligne calvados ici je
vis au classement le chef de cabinet des
idées de bêtes bornes étaient sous
préfet dans les îles du nord peu de ceci
explique peut-être cela est voulu jouer
à domicile et jouer safe entre
guillemets pour le premier déplacement
oui je crois que le calvados est une
terre centriste pro-européenne un
territoire qui va plutôt bien donc
effectivement les risques sont mesurés
n'empêche j'ai envoyé le premier
ministre au front c'est un vrai baptême
du feu électoral donc là aussi je pense
qu'elle va devoir aller gagner ses
galons de général politique pour aller
conforter aussi ses troupes et incarner
ce rôle de chef de la majorité qui pour
l'instant est complètement incarnée par
le chef de l'état emmanuel macron l
internat cette circonscription tout et
pas toutes les circonscriptions
mais je pense que m
la première met dix ne sont pas
complètement stupide et ont quand même
trouvé malgré tout d'abord une
circonscription enfin un département
tout allait donc elle est originaire et
c'est une circonscription qui est
aujourd'hui détenue par par la majorité
présidentielle et qui devrait le rester
évidemment à noter c'est la première
fois qu'elle se présente dans une
élection qu'elle n'a jamais été élu et
ça aussi c'est un petit handicap dans
mais son parcours exceptionnel de
compétences extrême technicienne et
c'est donc là c'est un risque prix très
très très minime mais quand même
manquer l'un des plus vieux autour de la
table je me souviens d'alain juppé a
perdu son sous ministre au ministère
d'état une pétition ça tu sors dix
circonscriptions gagnables
ou pas je rappelle qu emmanuel macron a
demandé à la ministre anne espagne
orange il a voulu qu'elle se retire
qu'ils ne se présentent pas dans une
relation conscription du de lance du pas
de calais qui était perdre à est ce que
au motif qu'il aurait peut-être besoin
d'elle plus tard c'est à dire au
gouvernement et si elle perd 17
circonscriptions elle aurait dû sortir
du gouvernement donc il a dit vous
n'irez pas fanny va pas on va on va
évidemment parler de la formation du
nouveau gouvernement de ses équilibres
qui sont subtiles mais jour un chapitre
puisque on a commencé à parler de jean
luc mélenchon sur cette question de la
laïcité quand même fait des potiers
c'est une vraie ligne de fracture au
sein de la nuque il ya ps pc d'un côté
on schématise un peu mais quand même
elle est fille europe ecologie les verts
de l'autre et
c'est peut-être même facteur de
dissidence pour dans certaines
circonscriptions absolument quand on
reprend les déclarations de campagne de
fabien roussel ou les déclarations
d'anne hidalgo calmes on est sur un camp
à celle à y voir là rica républicain
puis l'autre côté on a la frange plutôt
gauche de la france insoumis ce qui est
quand même il faut utiliser le mot
communautariste donc là il ya un vrai
clivage une vraie différence de vue et
ils vont tenter de surmonter cette
différence différences d'opinion
alors mélenchon jean luc mélenchon à
vous dire que sur les 650 proposition de
l'anip la peine 33 où il ya un désaccord
n'empêche que sur ces 33 il ya des
choses importantes comme la laïcité
c'est pas une petite nuance quand même
quoi
vous reprenez un élément de langage
parce que ça a été posée par emmanuel
macron quand il était à aubervilliers
voir c'est trop pour les législatives ça
a été très clair c'est lui qui a dit
voilà comment on va rentrer dans cette
bataille électorale et voilà ce que vous
allez dire et il a dit vous allez dire
effectivement que jean luc mélenchon le
mélenchonisme et du communautarisme
l'ailé gauche je l'apprends
affirmative ils sont communautaristes si
vous êtes ya peut-être un certain
clientélisme électoralistes en faveur de
certains combien taris mais dire comme
ça affirmé par la presse sont vos propos
je trouve que c'est au pied très bien
c'est bien qu'on soit pas d'accord sur
tout sur ce plateau stéphane zumsteeg su
si on analyse un peu l'opinion face à ce
débat burqini et si on essaye d'élargir
laïcité le burqini idée rejetée par une
majorité de français est question
subsidiaire mais même au sein de
surdoses l'année gauche surtout
les personnes qui sont les plus en
pointe mais cet historique de toute
façon ça ça ne date pas de cette année
les gens qui sont les plus tatillons sur
le respect de la laïcité et donc ils
sont les puces qui se révèlent les plus
opposés
notamment au burkina sont souvent des
gens qui viennent de la gauche voire 2
la france a subi il ya des enquêtes qui
ont été réalisés très récemment voit
bien que ce sont des gens qui ont voté
notamment pour jean luc mélenchon ou
pour les autres candidats de gauche qui
sont les plus réservés à l'égard de
cette décision grenobloise ce qui pose
quand même un problème vous évoquiez les
dissidences tout à l'heure mais je ne
crois pas beaucoup à des candidats
dissidents de gauche par dont notamment
des candidats du parti socialiste afin
de carole delga en occitanie ces gens là
ne seront probablement pas au second
tour ne devant seront pas des candidats
de la nuque mais en revanche pas
grignoter quelques points et comme on a
déjà eu l'occasion d'en parler on est
dans un dans un contexte où l'abstention
devrait être forte où il y aura très peu
de triangulaires l'objectif c'est d'être
dans les deux premiers si vous perdez 2
3 4 % au profit d'un dissident locale ça
peut vous empêcher d'adam des deux
premiers et donc vous perdez cette
circonscription ça pourrait
éventuellement coûter cher à la nuque
dans son ensemble il ya un autre il ya
un autre élément important et on le voit
bien avec la stratégie du président de
la république et le déplacement
d'elisabeth bornes l'idée c'est de faire
peur
longtemps emmanuel macron à jouer le
match contre marine le pen contre leur
rassemblement national nom d'
extrêmement il faut pas que l'extrême
droite avec vos pouvoirs il adopte
exactement le même discours mais en
changeant cette fois-ci d'adversaires là
encore il y a ce n'est pas marginal ces
minorités mais il ya une part de
l'électorat historique social démocrate
écologiste dans les centres urbains qui
à un moment donné pourrait être pourrait
se mettra hésité ces gens là ont voté
utile au dernier moment pour jean luc
mélenchon ces gens là face à des
polémiques comme ça du burkini
pourraient y réfléchir à deux fois et
finalement soit voter pour un candidat
ma chronique soit s'abstenir et ça aussi
ça pourrait coûter cher à l'onu il est
très clair qu effectivement là la
stratégie des manuels macron pendant la
campagne c'était d'évoquer le péril brun
le péril marine le pen est
qu'aujourd'hui tout est focalisé sur le
péril rouge jean luc mélenchon
d'ailleurs il ne s'en cache pas il
s'exprime comme ça c'est ce qu'il a dit
effectivement devant les candidats aux
us et yves à aubervilliers il agite le
chiffon rouge pourquoi parce que je
pense qu'il est assez inquiète néanmoins
de comment ça va se passer dans
l'hémicycle
le premier quinquennat on avait dix sept
députés français soumise et qu'ils ont
je pense qu'on peut de suture
reconnaître était assez bruyant font
uniquement 17 députés imaginez là s'il y
en a entre eux allez on va dire soyons
large entre 120 et 150 voix là et je
pense qu emmanuel macron ça va être
d'autant plus bruyant c'est ce que je
veux dire je pense qu emmanuel macron
sait que ça va être très compliqué que
les deux extrêmes très sonore comme ça
dans l'hémicycle cette règle quinquennat
compliquée à mener est compliquée à
mener sur les réformes donc c'est pour
ça qu'il il envoie la focale
effectivement sur ce péril rouge alors
vous l'avez expliqué stéphane il y à ce
système du scrutin majoritaire à deux
tours parce que quand on voit les
sondages la nuque arrive pas dans tous
mes souvent en tête en pourcentage de
voix au premier tour devant
ensemble devant l'alliance de la
majorité présidentielle mais évidemment
iman mac on devrait avoir une majorité
sans doute absolu prudent à l'assemblée
ça agace les insoumis laetitia et il
commence à communiquer sur le thème
attention ces élections sont tronqués
oui en fait il reste dans cette vague
impulsée par jean luc mélenchon au soir
de sa défaite il faut rappeler quand
même parce que c'est vrai que quand on
écoute jean luc mélenchon on a toujours
l'impression qu'il est victorieux il a
perdu l'élection présidentielle et donc
il a dit voilà le les élections
législatives ont constitué un troisième
tour est la nouvelle alliance de la
gauche va gagner ce troisième tour et
donc c'est bien sûr de la communication
thomas vous savez bien mais il ya
toujours un peu de vrai dans la
propagande pourquoi parce que elle est
comme ça elle est efficace et c'est vrai
quand on regarde des projections les
premières projections que en nombre de
voix au premier tour la nuque baisse ou
la nuque arriverait devant la majorité
présidentielle réunis sous le patronyme
ensemble et donc ils en font finalement
le socle de la stratégie de
communication qui vont marteler on va
l'entendre l'entendre l'entendre nous
serons les premiers d'accord et ils
prennent uniquement pour postulat ce
premier tour c'est ça en fait c'est une
vérité parcellaire et ça aussi c'est une
caractéristique de la propagande parce
que oui ils seront au premier tour mais
vous l'avez dit le nombre de voix ne se
convertit pas forcément et là dans le
cas pas du tout en nombre de sièges et
donc normalement avocat selon les
premières projections ensemble aurait la
majorité absolue et ensuite à partir de
là ils construisent un argumentaire
qu'on connaît bien qu on a notamment
entendu dans la bouche le donald trump
en 2020 après sa défaite l'argumentaire
qui dit ce sont des élections volées ils
n'iront peut-être pas jusque là mais au
moins on aura ce sentiment d' élections
tronquées ou au moins un sincère oui ils
veulent imposer cette idée que le
scrutin est faussée et alors ils
s'appuient là pour le coup sûr une
décision administrative du ministère de
l'intérieur qui a été prise là il ya
quelques jours et qui a refusé
d'inscrire la nuque baisse comme une
nuance ce politique on va écouter les
explications de julien bayou qui est le
secrétaire général de europe écologie
secrétaire nationale d'europe écologie
les verts et sofia shigeru conseillère
communications de jean luc mélenchon
tous deux sont candidats aux
législatives quand on dépose une
candidature on dit en fait à quel bloc à
quelles nuances politiques on veut être
rattachés et nous évidemment on souhaite
être rattaché à la nuance du ps la
nouvelle union populaire écologiques et
sociales pour que les différentes
candidatures soient considérés et
additionnés pour qu'on voit le vrai
rapport de force au soir du premier tour
ça une vraie importance de le retracer
la sincérité du scrutin hélas le
ministère de l'intérieur a publié une
circulaire au dernier moment qu'ils
refusent qu'on puisse comptabiliser du
ps comme une nuance qui est étonnant
c'est qu'ils n'ont eu aucun problème
enregistré ce qui est à peu près la même
chose c'est-à-dire une coalition de
partis ensemble
s'est enregistrée par le ministère de
l'intérieur en revanche la nuit il est
de nous effacer jusque dans l'épaisse
c'est vrai qu'on pourrait avoir aussi
une tentative de communication de la
part de la majorité présidentielle qui
au soir du premier tour pourra dire va
regarder la gauche est divisée mais bref
on est là en plein coeur d'une bataille
de communication qui a pour témoin
l'opinion publique c'est à dire potier
ou dit quoi jean luc mélenchon éternel
mauvais joueur c'est ce qui se prépare
c'est comment un asus a
fait monter en épingle parce qu'il ya
d'une part les nuances des candidats à
la fal étiquette qu'il souhaite utiliser
ça chacun est libre de se déclarer de
gauche de droite d'extrême gauche d'être
note simplement derrière il ya des
analystes il ya des retraitements
statistique est par exemple si on ne
retenait que l'auto qualification des
candidats bah ça poserait aussi les
problèmes de lisibilité par amp le front
national n'a jamais reconnu cette
étiquette d'extrême droite donc les
classifications du ministère de
l'intérieur elles sont pour lusage du
ministère de l'intérieur après que des
candidats comique sur leurs propres
nuances c'est leur bon droit mais là ce
qui est évoqué comme un mauvais procès
où ce qui est cool évoqué comme une
manoeuvre moi ça me paraît très
exagérées vous dites l'argument de la
nuque ou delà du ps puisque
manifestement et 19 aces et
nous voulons rejeté cet argument est
al'inverse parce que ma question c'était
jean luc mélenchon est joueur et cette
façon de de près vous afin de commencer
à dire que ce scrutin il est tronquée et
s'est mis à danser là où jean luc
mélenchon jouer avec le feu parce que
ils les nonces
une hypothèse qui est hautement
improbable serre qu'ils gagnent qui
deviennent près ministre est c'est fort
probable que cette hypothèse ne se
réalise pas et il va en rejeter la faute
sur le système les autres et donc il va
nourrir un procès en illégitimité et ça
c'est extrêmement dangereux parce que eh
bien ça ébranle les fondations mêmes de
notre démocratie je trouve que c'est
complètement spéciaux effectivement
comme procès que tente de faire jean luc
mélenchon est et las nubes où la france
font mise derrière c'est très simple
pour s'inscrire en préfecture faut que
le parti soit enregistré une structure
voilà ce qui est le cas de ensemble
ensemble la confédération de la majorité
présidentielle qui regroupe le modem
agir et désormais renaissance à une
existence juridique donc quand on va en
préfecture quand n'importe quel candidat
qu'il soit modem ou je ne sais quoi en
préfecture il peut s'inscrire ensemble
ce qui n'est pas le cas de la nuque ou
de l'avenue pèse qu ils n'ont pas
d'existence et pains pas ruiner
rousserie aussi par le système de
financement en revanche le artistes en
lice le parti socialiste où la france a
sionistes ont une existence juridique
donc là c'est différent elle est là et
ce qu'a rappelé d'ailleurs scène cela ce
gars là niel patron de renaissance
récemment il a dit rien n'empêchera le
soir des élections les médias ou même
les statisticiens que vous évoquez de de
présenter les résultats de la nuque ou
de la nuit pesme sous un seul sigle
voilà donc encore une fois je pense
vraiment que c'est assez très spéciaux
comme arguments et c'est un mauvais
procès stéphane seiller il ya en tout
aussi se dire qu'il ya une forme de
cohérence de la part de jean luc
mélenchon qui rejette le la vème
république qui veut changer le système
et donc de critiquer finalement ce mode
de scrutin qui ne tient pas compte d'une
force politique qui s'exprimera au
premier tour
il a toujours milité pour la 6
république c'est vrai mais de là à s'en
prendre directement aux institutions
actuelles et de parler d'un cesse d'un
sincérité du scrutin je pense que là il
franchit une nouvelle étape que moi je
trouve très contestable surtout quand on
est un homme d'état comme
jean luc mélenchon il a obtenu 22% des
voix ce ne sont pas des révolutionnaires
des gens qui ont voté pour lui ne
veulent pas changer complètement le
système social et politique en france
dont je pense qu'il va très loin c'est
aussi une façon d'abord de faire parler
de lui mais vous avez tous raison c'est
une tempête dans un dans un verre d'eau
ce qui s'est passé là et on parlait de
statistique c'est pas compliqué
d'additionner quatre scores lescar des
communistes des insulines des
socialistes et des écologistes ce point
devrait y arriver y compris les
journalistes en plateau le sud une
journée par les plus matures je pense
que beaucoup de français ils y
arriveront au delà c'est un moyen aussi
de masquer un certain nombre de choses
parce que on parle beaucoup de cette
dynamique qui réel de la nuit baisse
mais il ya énormément de handicap
qu'elle va affronter et alors est ce que
c'est une façon donc une défaite ça je
ne sais pas de leur part je ne suis pas
à leur place mais le vrai problème de la
nuit passe c'est que
elle a des bastions en france il ya 577
circonscriptions une faune vous évoquez
les enquêtes d'opinion ou en général
avant de parler de projections en sièges
et en pourcentage de voile et à peu près
au même niveau parfois un peu en tête
face à la majorité présidentielle mais
structurellement géographiquement il ya
un vrai des avantages pause qu'ils ont
des bastions où ils sont forts on voit
la périphérie des grands centres urbains
ils sont très faibles ailleurs or pour
disposer compte tenu du mode de scrutin
et de la territorialisation des
élections législatives pour disposer
d'une majorité faut être bon partout
phosphate bon et c'est ce qui est le cas
notamment de d'emmanuel macron quand on
analyse son score lors de l'élection
présidentielle donc ils feront des bons
scores mais dans un nombre insuffisant
de circonscription pour espérer
l'emporter on va parler maintenant de la
formation de ce gouvernement emmanuel
macron elisabeth board on dit
aujourd'hui qu'il fallait prendre son
temps
on écoute le président de la république
le travail continue de manière sérieuse
mais ce n'est pas ce n'est pas une chose
légère elle requiert du temps les
échanges de fond et c'est ce que la
première ministre et moi même faisons
donc autant de temps qu utile et que
nécessaire car il s'agit du gouvernement
de la france
alexandre tout ça peut nous rejoindre
bonsoir alexandre bienvenue vue on va
rappeler que composer un gouvernement
c'est respecter un subtil équilibre
quelles sont les règles d'usagé
alors thomas la première règle d'usagé
bien c'est la parité en 2022 il faut
avoir un gouvernement paritaire avec
autant de ministres femmes que d'hommes
d'ailleurs tous les gouvernements du
premier quinquennat d'emmanuel macron
été paritaire même chose sous le
quinquennat de françois hollande en
revanche ce n'était pas le cas avant
sous nicolas sarkozy ou sous jacques
chirac ensuite il faut respecter des
équilibres politiques et pour emmanuel
macron c'est pas toujours évident il
faut aussi entre la gauche et la droite
et cette année il faut que toutes les
composantes de la majorité
présidentielle soit représentée avec
évidemment renaissance le parti central
le modem le principal allié désormais il
faut compter avec horizon le parti
d'edouard philippe et puis avec
territoire de progrès qui représente
l'ailé gauche de la majorité et dans
lequel il y avait deux bornes la
nouvelle première ministre et puis faut
faire aussi un petit peu de place aux
ralliés récent des républicains ou du
parti socialiste dans cet équilibre est
aussi l'idée est bien du poids politique
de certaines figures en l'occurrence
bruno le maire ou gérald darmanin 2
avoir un portefeuille ministériel
sauf s'il ne souhaite pas rempiler ça
peut arriver c'est par exemple le cas
normalement de jean yves le drian qui
devrait arrêter après dix ans dans des
gouvernements et puis il faut également
en équilibre géographique que tous les
territoires toutes les régions de france
soit bien représentée sans oublier
l'effet de surprise emmanuel macron aime
bien l'effet de surprise en 2017 il
avait nommé nicolas hulot à l'écologie
et puis plus récemment souvient de
l'avocat eric dupond moretti qui
arrivait à la justice ou encore de
roselyne bachelot sorti de sa retraite
politique qui était nommé au ministère
de la culture
au final ça fait tellement de critères
tellement et bien deux lignes de logique
à prendre en compte que a finalement
nommé composer un gouvernement ce n'est
même plus rationnelle sur ce point on va
écouter le patron de presse denis
olivennes il était il ya deux jours sur
notre plateau il connaît bien le sujet
puisqu'il y a trente ans il était le
conseiller du premier ministre de
françois mitterrand pierre bérégovoy
lorsqu'il rentrait à matignon
il se trouve que j'ai assisté dans le
bureau de pierre bérégovoy premier
ministre est à la composition de son
gouvernement il est au téléphone avec le
président de la république et tout à
coup il a somme de hasard créé le
personne de cartes final c'est
complètement incroyable ijan nom à
l'époque on a même eu un homonyme qui
avait été nommé la place d'un autre
quelqu'un est nommé avait une position
parce qu'il est compétent pays bas n'ont
ils moins qu'un breton passant est un
breton et à la fin ça ressemble bien
davantage un jeune bonne tout cas une
partie d'échecs voilà la stratégie
politique a ses limites quand on compose
merci alexandre et merci d'avoir
ressorti cette très jeune archives
puisque c'était effectivement en début
de semaine faisait potier ça nous rend
parce que là on va s'amuser les uns les
autres peut-être un peu au jeu des
pronostics mais ça rend forcément humble
quand on imagine que tout ça peut
changer jusqu'au tout dernier moment oui
le casting il est difficile à établir on
peut leur ajoutant les autres critères
un équilibre entre des miss techniciens
et la société civile oui il faut aussi
concilier des binômes de ministres parce
que parfois on a un ministre d'état où
un ministre délégué avec un secrétaire
d'état et donc tout ça forme une
architecture fragile équilibre et
subtile et le dernier critère auquel
le faut penser c'est que aujourd'hui il
ya des vérifications notamment des
situations fiscales qui n'existait pas
il ya cinq dix ans et donc c'est vrai
que ça prend un peu plus de temps il a
autorité sur la transparence
effectivement mais fier à mon avis des
ministres médiatique parce que vous avez
vu avec nicolas hulot ce que ça a donné
les parties quand même là qu'est la
porte on est des prisons eric dupond
moretti
devrait normalement partir aussi donc
les ministres un peu coup vous voyez il
faut quand même se méfier je crois qu
emmanuel macron quand même couru après
un ce type de mini vation commence à
comprendre qui est préférable parfois de
s'en méfier surtout quand on a nommé et
il avait deux bornes en chef au robinet
il cherche de l'efficacité alain tout
ils cherchent s'il est très conscient de
la parité
voilà et son problème en fait c'est que
les fameux poids lourds qu'alexandre
évolué qui ont plus fait un bond
quinquennat précédent que donc il
souhaiterait garder on les connaît
gérald darmanin bruno le maire ils sont
quelques-uns comme ça malheureusement ce
ne sont que des hommes donc c'est là
aussi où il a un problème c'est que
c'est bien ils voudraient reconduire
cela certes mais enfin il ya un problème
de parité un problème d' équilibre
politique avec notamment effectivement
le modem de françois bayrou et horizons
d'edouard philippe donc tout ça ça prend
du temps puis en plus en général les
remaniements c'est toujours le dernier
moment c'est où c'est le plus compliqué
oui bah oui quand les derniers
arbitrages
bien des injonctions contradictoires
d'une certaine façon ils restent
stéphane d'obstacles moins d'un mois
avant le premier tour de cette élection
de ces élections législatives est-ce
qu'elle va forcément se jouer sur les
mêmes thèmes que la présidentielle
notamment le pouvoir d'achat ces mecs-là
semble le plus évident le poids d'achat
reste la principale préoccupation des
gens c'est ça ne changera pas après il
ya des thèmes qui sont toujours au coeur
des attentes des français mais dont on a
moins parlé durant la d'expression c'est
mais dont on va davantage parler
notamment maintenant que qu'elle connut
deux noms de l'hôte de matignon
l'éducation la santé vont être des
thèmes qui vont être beaucoup quand je
parle de santé le papa de kevin je pars
du système de santé en général
l'éducation sont des thèmes qui étaient
présents mais qui n'était pas
omniprésent et qui vont le devenir
beaucoup plus d'autres fins d'autant
plus que si la nomination d'elizabeth
borne est là pour essayer de convaincre
une partie des français de la sincérité
des manuels macron quand il a annoncé
l'inflexion sa politique de politiques
plus écologisme que d une politique plus
soucieuse des problématiques sociales il
va bien être obligé le gouvernement et
le président la république vont bien
être obligés de parler beaucoup plus
qu'auparavant de ces sujets là donc moi
je m'attends on parlera d'écologie
évidemment maison et un engagement on
attend la nomination des deux ministres
russe et binou
évidemment mais qui sera la santé qui
sera l'éducation nationale sont des
vrais enjeux et je reviens sur ce terme
c'est le principal enjeu pour emmanuel
macron sait convaincre les français de
la sincérité de l' inflexion de sa
politique pour l'instant on ne le crois
pas parce qu'on ne croit pas les hommes
et des femmes peules il dessert général
voilà je trouve moi que la nomination
d'elizabeth borne est plutôt bien vu
d'un point de vue purement pragmatique
c'est une expression qu'on a entendu de
ces jours-ci al koch toutes les cases
l'encoche d'affaires comme maintenant il
faut attendre la nomination un parent
des ministres et dont on verra bien
edouard première décision de la première
déclaration on verra bien si emmanuel
macron va aller jusqu'au bout de ce
qu'il a annoncé juste avant le second
tour de la présidentielle
vous qui avez analysé sept
regardez demanda de des modèles macron
dans ce livre résurrection comment il
peut fonctionner ce doux
mâcon bornes là parce qu'il faut aussi
qu'ils trouvent leurs marques quoi je
pense que déjà justement s'il a choisi
c'est qu'il a déjà travaillé avec elle
je rappelle qu isabelle borne a été
ministre pendant tout le quinquennat
trois postes différents qu'il sait à qui
il a à faire il dit c'est avec qui va
travailler et c'est aussi une expression
qu'on a entendu elizabeth banks un peu
une castex au féminin - le côté élu
local parce que comme vous le rappelez
les dix elle n'a jamais été élu en
revanche c'est une technocrate c'est une
bosseuse c'est une sorte d' un peu une
super collaboratrice comme l'a été et
comme ça a très bien marché avec jean
castex et on comprend très bien pourquoi
ils cherchent ce type de profil ce qui
n'a pas fonctionné avec edouard philippe
c'était à la fin en tout cas la rivalité
entre l'elysée et matignon
edouard philippe et pascal edwards finit
pas pris un point politique qu'il avait
pas forcément au début du quinquennat m
rappelons-nous mais dès le début du
quinquennat edouard philippe a refusé le
directeur de cabinet que voulait lui
imposer emmanuel macron voilà donc je
pense qu'avec il isabelle borne
emmanuel macron trouve une personne avec
qui il va pouvoir travailler collaboré
comme il l'a fait avec jean castex à lui
convient très bien qui est là en plus
c'est une femme c'était une des
promesses qu'il avait faites aux
français ni côté justement si on analyse
un peu la composition du cabinet
d'elisabeth bornes qu'est ce qui vous
frappe alors ce qui me frappe c'est que
c'est quand même beaucoup des techno qui
viennent kg de la gauche c'est le cas
d'aurélien au souk était au cabinet de
manuel valls et bernard cazeneuve c'est
aussi le cas d'une partie des
conseillers intérieur donc on voit
plutôt cette mouvance la républicaine
technocratique de gauche maintenant ce
qui est aussi capital dans les
nominations c'est le choix des dires cap
des autres ministères c'est alors qui va
être le dircab du ministre de l'économie
et des finances de l'écologie de
l'éducation d'achat parce qu'on sait
bien que ce réseau d dircab ils jouent
un rôle fondamental dans le bon
fonctionnement de l'état on va parler
d'eux d'une autre actualité politique du
jour maintenant dernier chapitre dans ce
premier débat de sens public christian
jacob qui place damien abad face à ses
responsabilités avec ce communiqué
donc il parle de damien abad il m'a
réclamé un délai supplémentaire pour
attendre la composition du gouvernement
dans ces conditions je lui ai signifié
qu'on ne pouvait pas attendre le bon
vouloir de monsieur macron de le prendre
ou de ne pas le prendre au gouvernement
et qu'il devait dès maintenant quitter
ses fonctions de président du groupe
s'avère large et qui faisait quoi il
jouait la montre dames yade c'est ça
actuellement mais comme emmanuel macron
m étirer le temps est trop il s'est fait
il s'est fait prendre à son propre jeu
j'allais dire je crois qu'il va annoncer
ce soir que pour le tamis ramadan il va
annoncer publiquement pour le coup dans
une interview au figaro à nos confrères
du figaro qu'il effectivement qui le
groupe l'est républicain le sans doute
forcé voilà mais est-ce qu'il sera nommé
demain j'en sais rien parce que comme
comme on vient de le dire voilà ses
rimes tel jeu une bonne tripotée le
moment ils risquent de il risque de tout
leur poids iris et c'est un vrai risque
ça c'est la politique car il semble bien
sûr mais parce que qu'est ce qui va se
passer il ya un effet nos vidéos c'est
ensuite dans sa circonscription il va
avoir dix à avoir un candidat et l'air
en face de lui mais je comprends je
comprends quand même les républicains
qui déjà ne sont pas très vaillant en ce
moment pied qui partent dans cette
élection sans chef sans stratégie sans
ligne et en plus voilà alors leurs chefs
de file ont des janissaires des pudeurs
de gazelle en fonction d'eux des
promesses que leurs fonds emmanuel
macron donc je les comprends tout à fait
effectivement le latitude est un peu
ferme de christian jacob aujourd'hui
avec en marqueur quand même ultime les
-2 5% à l'élection présidentielle de
valérie pécresse c'est ça le boulet je
ne sais pas comment ils vont s'en
défaire d'ailleurs des républicains
parce que finalement françois fillon
avait échoué mais on le sait avec un
score qui était quand même honorable par
rapport aux affaires qu'il avait qui
avait supporté il avait souhaité rester
mais vraiment le score de valérie
pécresse c'est ça enterre quoi quasiment
définitivement les républicains donc se
renouveler
bon sang mais très compliqué le choc est
tellement violent qu'effectivement on
peut comprendre cette espèce de 2
de paralysie qu'il est saisi depuis
depuis plusieurs semaines ses fans zone
cei et même accro et du alors on se sait
pas si damien abad fera partie de ce
gouvernement à ils étaient reçus à
l'élysée oui voilà il fait partie des
probables on va dire ça comme ça mais
balma quoi il est dans sa stratégie
continue de siphonner alors ya les
hommes et ce qui continue s'il faisait
siphonner cet électorat de la droite on
va dire de gouvernement il n'a pas varié
d'un iota en cinq ans un de la
nomination d'edouard philippe ebel
crimes jusqu'à aujourd'hui mais qu'est
ce qui a changé dans la stratégie des
beignets le maquereau oui ce qui a
changé c'est l'imprévu l'imprévu nubes
prévu mélenchon mais évidemment qu'il
continue que l'objectif c'est vraiment
de mettre à mort définitivement les
républicains est-ce qu'ils disparaîtront
tout de suite non probablement pas mais
on parlait des scores du score de
valérie pécresse elne et tentait dans
aucune circonscription premier tour de
la présidentielle et malgré tout il ya
120 130 130 députés de droite dont une
centaine étiqueté elle est
ce groupe s'oriente vers une catastrophe
électorale il ya certains qui survivront
pas ce qu'il ya malgré tout un ancrage
local dans certaines zones mais je peux
pas y avoir de prime aux sortants pour
quelle cause bic en mairie me sortant il
ya toujours une prime sur m6 mais alors
déjà depuis qu'il n'ya plus depuis que
le cumul des mandats a été supprimée
vous n'avez plus de députés maires ou de
sénateur mais bien que vous ne pouvez
pas vous profité du fait que vous
dirigez la plus grande ville d'une
circonscription tout ça comme fortement
rogné l'ancrage local évidemment mais
maintenant plus généralement ce qui
concerne ses députés républicains ils
sont en situation dans une posture très
compliqué je reviens sur ce que je
disais tout à l'heure il n'y a que les
deux premiers qui seront qualifiés parce
qu'il n'y aura quasiment aucune
triangulaire peut-être quelques unes
mais ce sera marginal effet dans les
deux premiers comment voulez vous êtes
dans les deux premiers alors que votre
candidate a obtenu quelques semaines
avant moins de 5% des voix le risque est
grand de voir des dizaines et des
dizaines de députés l air est limité
éliminé pas battu au second tour mais
éliminé dès le premier tour le seule
circonscription où éventuellement il
pourrait un peu mieux s'en sortir
qu'ailleurs c'est dans des sacs ou dans
certaines circonscriptions de l'est de
la france où le rassemblement national
est très forts et sûrs et des duels lr
et rennes et là pour le coup ce sont des
sortants et l'eire qui qui qui
l'emporterait mais ailleurs la tâche va
être très très dur free potier lr qui
doit se choisir un nouveau chef cet
homme ce que christian jacob a annoncé
que passer la main à l'issue de ces
élections législatives sur quelle ligne
politique assez de doute sans doute
plutôt à droite de la
difficulté pour les américains que les
poids lourds du gouvernement seront
probablement encore issues des
républicains et que dans le discours de
politique générale peut être que des
marqueurs de droite qui dureront aussi
je pense à la retraite par exemple ça un
sujet classique deloitte d'autres sujets
sur la sécurité aussi si gérald darmanin
reste place beauvau et donc c'est avec
les républicains pour être écartelée
entre d'une part un électorat qui aura
beaucoup voté macro et puis de l'autre
côté une puissance d'attraction du rn
qui va sortir
assez renforcé quand même de cette
séquence là merci beaucoup merci à tous
les trois d'avoir participé à ce débat
sa verrière j'avais frappé le titre de
votre livre résurrection et donc publié
aux éditions stock les coulisses d'une
reconquête
et puis frédéric potier
thriller politique le titre c'est la
menace celle 132e raconte quoi tu viens
c'est démocratie française dans un
contexte de tensions et de coup d'état
passionnant c'est aux éditions de l'aube
merci encore à tous les trois